getting scary getting scary political
talks are scary my friend um this is
political powers um an episode actually
I'm really endorses lying but I dude
you're gonna go on Avatar Canyon on this
aren't you yes and no oh wow no no cuz
it's like I want to see a freak out
sister there I'm not a politician uh and
it's you know anyone that knows me knows
I hate I really hate politics left right
at all that's the super tricky except
for 208a yeah he's a darling Trump's at
darling he's going all the way
oh but yeah but I hate all that stuff
but and I don't like all that yeah the
corruption the lying you know all that
stuff at the same time I can't act like
I don't understand it or that we've
gotten so deep that there's this idea
like we can't just do Fight Club and
blow everything up and start from
scratch again so they're homemade we're
setting them free there has to be some
stability and there has to be compromise
and anyone that says oh that's the real
true honest politician and stuff it's
like almost by definition they can't
exist because people would just tear
them apart and panic and go insane I
think if we did guy to know the truth
you are Jack's raging rash decision it's
one of the things where it's like
anytime like censor new shocking thing
about the government comes out like when
they said we're all being Tad's we're
all being listened to I mean it's like
well that sucks but like didn't did we
always kind of know this I mean wasn't
there always kind of thought like yeah
we're all just kind of oh there's some
assholes who endorse that sort of thing
yeah I mean it's one of those things
where it's like just I always got figure
we have to give up our freedoms to
preserve our freedoms don't you get it
it's one of those things where it's like
I kind of already assume we're kind of
screwed in many ways so it's just make
what you can and just do what you can I
because like no no politician has only
and no one person has all the answers
nobody knows exactly how to fix things
you just have to go
with Doug kya the betta Donnell's would
disagree with
he clearly has all these you're wrong um
so cuz there is no I mean all these
politicians I mean like like many people
I don't trust a lot of them because
again it's just kind of a setup we've
made but it's kind of like we have to
make it because yeah if everybody did
know everything that was going on we
were hundred percent honest and stuff
like that people would freak I mean you
would just go insane and we do want to
hop on things and judge and panic and
you know all these things so it's like I
kind of understand it I don't like it
but I understand it's kind of how a lot
of it has to be so I wish I'd bought
some tap shoes for you but that that
really is my fault
like and I can't I don't know the answer
is either I don't know like hey this is
what needs to be this is what we need to
change I have no idea I'm not in
politics even if I was I wouldn't know
all the behind-the-scenes stuff so you
just got compromised and do the best
that you can and I kind of like that
there's something that says you know hey
yeah there is there's constant
manipulation everywhere even outside of
politics you just got to do the best
with it and there is a reason it exists
um and I said I don't like it and I
think there's some things that are worth
really pointing out and saying hey you
need to know the truth about this but
yeah if we worried about everything I
mean all the legit fears out there I
mean we would just we would never
fucking leave hell even if we stay in
our houses and friability things I can
kill us and stuff so it's one of those
things where you just gotta balance it
out and take the risks so I don't know I
just like that there's an episode that
says hey yeah there's a lot of lying a
lot of manipulation but there is a
reason for it and it's not all just to
consume and destroy your puny Minds
there is a legit reason of trying to
keep peace and harmony uh as well but I
don't know what I'd say you would have a
great career in politics no I don't I
don't want to know that shit I want to
stay my benign bubble um no it's one of
those things rain times like do you know
all the terrible things are going on
it's like no one I like it that way what
you don't believe it no I do believe it
that's the problem
Oh
you are the reason the world's got that
shit so um but yeah there's kind of a
point there too it's like how long do
you just say yeah whatever they'll
figure itself out I mean it's just
there's it's part of that balance you
have to vote you have to go out there
you have to make choices um my
philosophy always is if ignorance is
bliss weren't there more happy people so
um ya know I had all of that it's uh
soso there it is lying is okay you have
to vote words they're witty thing we
want you to do from candidate does I
don't believe in you oh I don't believe
in myself at uni the campaign slogan oh
I wish I could say he was on something
but I was here the whole time he wasn't
smoking anything okay well what did what
do you take out you think this episode
is just fear no we deserve to know
everything the truth and it's lying is
never ever good that me is that what
you've taken oh no I was completely fine
with enjoying making fun of you oh no
actually um but I like that Stephen does
say no I'm ready I want to know this you
know I like these engages myself as well
but he wouldn't have realized that had
he not overheard them so in theory had
he not just stumbled upon that first up
I got a call a little bit of bullshit
here
Stephen seems to have been here for most
of this and yet he can't put two and two
together they're like they're like
tiptoeing like at the beginning of the
episode they were completely tiptoeing
around to like oh when we meet with
peridot he has to have known yeah like
how could he not know I I heard the
message from lapis I mean I that seems
more like hey you were gonna bend you
know sort of logic a little bit to get
this message across but I agree with you
I'm like they're they're still
quote-unquote hiding this I mean there's
really going on the assumption though
that for some reason he doesn't he only
found out them by accident that he even
needed to inquire further otherwise they
could have been successful keeping in
the secret and who knows considering the
fact that Steven plays such an integral
part in the show and seems to help them
out
randomly what a fucking disaster that
would have been so no I don't think
lying is the best thing you can do well
no no not not necessarily lying thieving
whore no I think there is a time where
it's like I said there's always this
manipulation going on and I think a lot
of time it's done because they feel that
the people here didn't handle it but
Stephen stood up and said I can't handle
it please tell me if the mayor was lying
specifically to protect Stephen in the
Jemez I could kind of see that cuz they
were an angry unruly mob but I didn't
get that vibe from him I just got he
wanted to save his own ass and
everything oh yeah it's gonna be on to
that like is so well but and then it's
kind of weird cuz there was clearly a
politician at least has a plan they'll
lie but they'll have a plan for he had
no plan later that night I thought that
was a little weird well he had no plan
he had no second excuse he could have
just been honest in this much a says I
don't know what the issue is if he
didn't want to out them the Jemez like
sigh I feel I feel like no I like your
idea what a very weird like it would
have been stronger would have been
better you're right if it was to protect
Stephen and the gems uh because he knew
that wink anywhere quick at the vine no
I got it I got more just I want to
protect my own job sirs please don't
show me this crappy movie and I think
it's where he didn't want to spread
panic III I do legitimately believe that
um but but I think you're right it would
have been made stronger if it was to
protect the gems and Stephen and not
have this big battle going on cuz yeah
the gems are kind of like you know now
we're not doing that which I guess I
kinda get cuz they're trying to figure
out how to save the universe and
everything but it still seeing a little
douchey just like nope not doing it um
so I don't know it's it's tricky because
I think with okay like you have a child
and you're gonna tell a child that like
where Santa Claus exists then he doesn't
exist but like what point do you tell
them what point if it doesn't exist well
some find out later than others um but
it's one of those things where it's like
at what point do you let them know
she can't just let me know right away
you know it's hard to let kid know about
death right away or a war right away or
all these terrible things I think it's
the same way there's kind of like this
uh you know but he's a fucking Jim he's
not just an ordinary kid like if here's
the thing then they shouldn't have
brought him in on these adventures to
begin with if that's what they're really
concerned about then why the hell expose
him to any of this no fair point that's
a totally fair point I guess what I get
out of this is very much the what I
can't call the Lion King Cinderella
message which is like if you look at
this very literally the story does not
support the message but the message I
think is still very clear so it's kind
of like pick your poison um with both
Cinderella and liking like I got the
message but I'm still like this this
doesn't really follow through with
what's actually going on the story
technically if you really look at it but
most people watching don't look at the
details I think they look at the overall
picture I know it did anybody know they
loved him but that still doesn't
necessarily make it right um like that
did certainly yeah I mean it was not a
good call no I don't think that was the
point though I think the point was to
show that when people do hide stuff it's
not always to hurt you a lot of times
it's to protect you I think that's the
main message and a lot of times in
politics I think that is true a lot of
times it's not they are doing it just to
hide their own asses and get away with
terrible things um but I think there is
like it's always like if there's a lie
or a secret or something it's
automatically bad you know it's just
something terrible and it but there are
times where I mean at least I can say in
my life where it's like I wasn't ready
to hear something or I had to discover
it but it okay so they have the reasons
I'm just saying that doesn't mean that
the decision they made was right they
did it out of fear out of love around of
whatever but it it it's like it just
confuses me because again they seem to
be wrapping him up in all of this gem
stuff and then all of a sudden I go no
now we have to keep it a secret
no if you I get to the technicals I
Ryan I think there's probably a better
stronger way that this could have been
done I would have been pissed again I
think I think you're right I think but
there is kind of it I think because
there is that inconsistency with like
him quote unquote not figuring it out
which you're right I mean he would know
this he was there he saw this a few
times I gotta be like it it's bothering
me from a storytelling perspective
because jenna is very telling I think's
been pretty strong but this is what
those case around like how could he not
like it it's like well then you that
means you were pretty much like
retooling this story in a way that it
did make sense just to support this
whole move that they did I don't know I
know you're right
I mean your unit you're not wrong about
that I can see how that would you know
drive a person a little man like hey
wait a minute like logically with
everything else this doesn't add a field
leader way to tell the same story well I
like your way I like the way about
trying to protect Steven and the gems
and you know or earth stop even protect
the people from them if they tried to
ride against them of course they would
probably wait to be you ship out of them
um yeah that that could have been shown
a little better - like why he's doing
this it would have been nice - I mean
they tap on it but a woman look nice if
they show that there really was kind of
this protective side of him that did
have this plane like he cares so much
they issued my ocean town or ocean city
or whatever yeah whatever happened to
that that was sad day dude you don't
know that was Atlantis you know you're
fucking read the papers do you man I I
am behind on it so much blood after
Trump said it was a good thing though
how those poor kids
but um and that puppy just one puppy in
the entire town Wow like a thousand
kittens and the baby seals can't forget
about the baby oh god it was a mess
someone's gonna do like I didn't bail on
Ocean City being destroyed by Ocean City
return soon um so no I know we're I see
where you're coming from and I can see
someone not liking this episode because
of that um hate it no bye sighs I see
your problems but I'm like there's
there's some issues going on here like
first and foremost just the plot points
not adding up and like he should have
known and if not that really didn't
explain why he was
hiding that I don't know no yeah you're
probably right it didn't bother me as
much because I thought it was a legit
interesting message but I agree they
could have gotten it cross Joseph's eyes
after going off on that avatar episode
that this one gets like the past so I
well no because it's still because I
didn't I didn't like no they don't
because they're so that much I didn't
freak out as much about it as you did
and this one I just thought you would be
like rebel rebel rebel no I I think it's
more because with them they never
stepped up they never want to know the
truth they they never wanted to
understand and I think with this one
Steven does want like the American
electorate okay Steven does want our
stand even the people kind of listen and
when Steven says the Steven says the
truth he says he was trying to protect
you because he cares about you that's
why this lie was made it was not I'm
gonna tell another lie on top of this
lie so I think that balance is out a
little bit more um and by the way that
episode I would not have minded as much
if egg didn't just make it up and stop
there I be that's where I'm just like I
don't know about this but um yeah even
then I can't say that was like I don't
know I didn't hear as much as everyone
else did about that ending to bother me
um but but it is tricky it's very hard
to say when it's right if it's even a
matter of right or wrong I mean
sometimes it's just what's the best
choice you can make or the you know the
less of two evils so um it's a tricky
subject and I can't act like and that's
probably why you're probably right that
with such a tricky subject matter like
there should have been a little bit more
thought put into the details of it so
that it added up a little bit more um
but it's such an interesting idea and
message and topic to talk about
especially for a kid show I didn't mind
it that bad but but you're right I would
have liked it a little stronger a little
better in the planning start off liking
episode and with saying I'm right you
would make a good politician thank you I
try vote Walker he will not be my vice
oh I thought I always was your vice
that's a good joke to end on by